Australia's raging bushfires have proven
devastating for the country's wildlife
but there are some success stories and
here's one a secret operation led by
uniquely trained firefighters has saved
the last of a rare tree species that
survived the dinosaur era the wall of my
pine trees once thought to be completely
extinct now number fewer than 200 it's
believed they've grown in Australia for
about this is not a typo 200 million
years and they're so fragile their
location has been kept secret so the
rescue mission had to be kept quiet -
and it also required military-like
precision firefighters were dropped
directly into the Grove to set up an
irrigation system and system Rather's
air tankers sprayed water from above so
that gave the trees added moisture to
resist the fires some trees did burn of
course that was unavoidable but
scientists say the species will survive
even though the trees have made it
through the Australian summer fires
officials say they're still under threat
from humans who could unintentionally
kill them with disease so they're saying
don't try to visit the wall of my Pines
the Australian government won't tell you
where they are Wow but I mean if you
could visit them walking in that little
pond or walking in 200 mil 200 200
million years in the past that's good to
know they've saved them yeah
you